SUSAN WOLFSON: Here are five
really interesting facts
about "Frankenstein."
Because the first
publication was anonymous,
all the first reviewers
of "Frankenstein"
assumed that such a
blasphemous horror could have
been written only by a man.
Victor Frankenstein animates his
creature by a mysterious spark.
There is not the lightning
of modern cinematic
interpretation.
Victor Frankenstein discovers
the secret of life in 1791,
the year that Mary
Shelley's parents met.
As he creates his
creature, it takes
him nine months, a Gothic parody
of normal human gestation.
Though popular culture
refers to Dr. Frankenstein,
Victor Frankenstein
is no doctor.
He's a brilliant
undergraduate science student.
"Frankenstein" was first
published in a short run
of only 500 copies.
And Princeton Rare Books
and Special Collections
owns one of these copies.
[MUSIC PLAYING]